foreign
welcome back to another episode of the
Addie Hour podcast I was just telling
today's two guests this is actually
episode 41 which is hard for me to
believe so we're continuing to move
forward continue to go strong I mean
again it's always been great just to see
the feedback from you all as listeners
people who have uh chased me down on
campus to tell me how important these
conversations have been people who've
reached out to me by email people I've
just seen the community who've told me
how much these conversations uh really
impact them and help them think through
aspects that you might be walking
through in your own life but also
different perspectives
um so today we have a really special
conversation as you all know I'm a
neuroscientist and we're going to be
really leaning into the Neuroscience
piece today but also thinking about
neuroscience and mental health research
and what that has to do with with
society and whether we feel like that's
impact or Flop or a little bit of both
so I'll throw that out there as a
provocative question for you all but I
have two great guests who are going to
join this conversation today Dr Diana
Martinez and Dr Steve Mahler I'll give
them both a little bit of an
introduction and that you hear from them
as well to start with Dr Deanna Martinez
she is a professor of Psychiatry at the
Columbia University Irving Medical
Center she's actually originally from
Texas went to college in Santa Fe New
Mexico where she studied philosophy she
then moved to New York state to attend
medical school with a plan to return to
Texas but instead she became a
psychiatrist who researches Neuroscience
the Neuroscience of addiction and has
also become a New Yorker in her own word
so maybe we'll hear more about that as
well
so in addition to her research career
she has two sons and as they grew up and
became teenagers she recognized and
realized that the science could be used
to have a conversation about drugs
health and safety so she now gives
seminars to parents and Educators and
high school students where she talks
about the risks of drugs and how
science-based education can be used to
improve safety so Diana thank you so
much for being here on the podcast and
thank you for all the work you do as
well oh thank you glad to be here and uh
you know I do love neuroscience and New
York City so good that's a good
combination good combination
our second guest is Dr Steve Mahler who
is an associate professor of
neurobiology and behavior at UC Irvine
he has a PHD in biopsychology from the
University of Michigan and has been
researching how addiction and other
psychiatric disorders work in terms of
work in the brains of both humans and
rodents and he's been doing this for
over 20 years today he's a behavioral
neuroscientist trying to understand how
processes in the brain go awry and
psychiatric disorders he uses rats as a
pre-clinical model he's someone who
loves to talk about Neuroscience I'll
also ask also add that he's a gifted
science communicator and he also is good
about really learning from established
scientists from the trainees he teaches
and from the mentors so a really
holistic approach in that sense not just
assuming that he knows all the
information is the the quote-unquote
expert in the room but really kind of
having collaborative conversations in
the work that he does it also does a lot
of impact in terms of having other
people communicate their science to the
public which is one of the reasons I was
really excited to have him here on the
podcast I want to welcome Dr Steve as
well
thank you so much me it's an honor to be
here
we'll definitely appreciate both of you
being here looking forward to jumping
into this conversation and just by way
of context for all of you the three of
us were actually together at a
conference last August uh Gordon
research conference on the neurobiology
of addiction
um and at that conference uh Steve was
reminding me that we actually heard a
very intriguing talk from Diana about
philosophy and how that actually impacts
how we think about addiction and
Neuroscience and mental health Stephen I
actually had a really extended
conversation after that really thought
provoking a lot of ways so we may Loop
that into this conversation today as
well but you all are really in for a
treat in terms of hearing from both of
these individuals and all the wonderful
work they're doing to really help us
think about things in a different way
and again we'll get back to that
question about where are we at as a
society in a field like do we actually
use and understand science as we should
or are there ways that we can improve so
and as I'm talking on screen I'm seeing
some head reactions from both our guests
so I know that there will be a lot to
talk about there but as my listeners
know I also like to just start checking
in with our guests just to see how
you're doing day to day
um in the state that we're in uh you
know this point May of 2023 with
everything we've experienced the last
few years everything that we're
continuing to navigate the new things
that we're navigating as well so Deanna
if we could just start with you and just
hear you know how are you doing today
and what occupies your day-to-day basis
ah good good question what can I say is
finally spring in New York it's finally
warm and one my older son is away at a
a broad semester abroad he's coming home
soon so I'm pretty excited him in a
while the longest I've gone without
seeing him and
um you know it's it's a great time it's
Grant season as usual you know we all
follow the cycles and certainly when it
comes to the news and current events you
know I try and and look for the
positives and hope for the best
um there's it's always a roller coaster
ride when we think of of current events
so um
but other than that you know things are
going great that's great to hear it
sounds like a refreshing time in a lot
of ways you know whispering things
you're anticipating I don't know if
you're anticipating with excitement for
a grant season in the same way your
anticipating have your son coming home
but maybe not but I actually actually
like writing grants like I like the
science of it I administrative part is
miserable but we have a fantastic
administrator who takes care of that so
it's actually kind of fun
that's great to hear that's really great
to hear something I've definitely shared
with people as well in terms of the
excitement for the ideas right and so
that's obviously you're in the right
place if that's that's your mode of
operation
um just as an aside to trainees who are
listening that's always something to pay
attention to as well because if that's
something that's completely onerous for
you all the way around you may want to
think about just different aspects you
want to get into or if there are aspects
of it that you like and some that you
don't also think creatively about what
would actually fit in terms of career
options
um and things you might be looking into
so just a little bit of inside you know
tidbit as we have that conversation
Steve why don't we uh jump to you and
see how you're doing these days
I'm doing pretty well
um the a lot of changes in my life over
the course of last few years
um as probably everyone can almost say
the same type of thing but in my case
um I got married I had my first baby uh
about this actually so thank you so
um you look very alert by the way
well everything is relative I guess but
um yeah it's been uh it's been really
fantastic you know really uh some ways
challenging in some ways it's a huge
change in my perspective on on life and
and on development even looking at kind
of um how my little daughter is learning
how to do different things and how they
come and kind of come online and it's
just really exciting to see these kinds
of things in person especially given
that we are doing some developmental
research in my lab as well trying to
understand some risk factors for
addiction and other kinds of psychiatric
disorders and trying to uh not do the
wrong thing it's always on my mind so uh
it's been fun but I yeah I wouldn't uh
trade it for anything that's great to
hear well thanks for giving us that that
full context too just in terms of Life
events and also how it's changing your
perspective
um as you move forward as well I mean in
some ways that's a similar theme between
the two of you granted maybe different
life stages but as Diana got into some
of her work in the schools as her sons
were getting older and then Steve as
you're thinking about the work you're
doing in the context of watching your
daughter grow and develop at these
really early stages of life as well so
it's refreshing to hear as well
so on that note maybe Steve will loop
back to you I just wanted to give our
listeners also a sense of how you got
how you both got into your professions
and if I can even go a step further to
say you're calling
um up to this point so anything you want
to share with our listeners about that
sure yeah um like most I think most
Scientific careers uh mine was not
something that I had in mind early on uh
it was uh definitely um one of those
things that just kind of Life comes at
you kind of thing so as an undergraduate
I was I I took my first class in
Psychology I think as a sophomore at
Loyola University in Chicago and I had a
great Professor so this is one of the
themes I think comes up in queers a lot
of times is you just have an inspiring
person that can kind of make you think
about uh you know the world in a
different way in some ways and um so I
got really interested in Psychology and
I started doing social psychology
research in my undergraduate time
um and I knew I was really interested in
Psychology but giving
um you know undergraduate psychology
students uh surveys was underwhelming
like I felt like there's there's a lot
of um ex you know all the really
interesting questions had been basically
asked already and you're kind of diving
into these more uh smaller and smaller
details and in some ways I I realized I
loved the scientific process but that
wasn't the way I wanted to go about it
and so unfortunately I didn't know what
I wanted to do so I applied to a bunch
of graduate schools uh thinking well
that's what people do in Psychology and
I think I applied to nine PHD programs
um and I got into none of them and um
mostly because I didn't know what I was
doing and so um I was fortunate that I
uh was my application was transferred to
a terminal Masters program at the
University of Chicago okay and I was
fortunate to meet another person that
was truly pivotal in my career um this
is Dr Harriet DeWitt who's a human
psychopharmacology researcher she kind
of wanted to know how drugs work in the
brain and how they change behavior and
and that kind of thing and
um and she really put me on into the
idea of Neuroscience of addiction and so
after doing some studies with her on
alcohol and nicotine especially and
craving and things like that and how
that relates to relapse and such I was
fortunate to get into the University of
Michigan the second time I applied to
PHD programs and worked with Kent
barrage who is a theorist of kind of
what is dopamine do in reward and
behavior and so on and so I did my um I
didn't actually work on dopamine too
much there but I did look at the some of
the the brain substrates now in rats of
addiction related behaviors or motivated
behaviors then into a postdoc I I
started to look more specifically at
addiction training rats to take drugs
and trying to understand what that does
in the brain and especially I'm going to
become more and more interested in
individual differences why some
individuals get addicted when they try
drugs and others don't and that's kind
of what's been driving me uh since then
and since I started my own lab about
eight years ago at in in Irvine
California I've really been trying to
dive into those issues and what's the
difference between you know someone who
gets addicted someone who doesn't
someone who has other kinds of
um
you know problems in terms of
psychiatric disorders depression and so
on as well so that's kind of in a
nutshell where how I got here yeah
that's great we'll definitely appreciate
the work that you do in terms of
understanding addiction but then also
some of the coexistence with other
psychiatric illnesses but then also just
appreciate the context that you gave as
well I mean I've said this several times
in several other contexts but I think
it's always helpful to hear people's
stories I mean there are aspects of your
story that I'm hearing for the first
time and also to learn about your
resilience and pivoting in the middle of
that too you know applying to nine
graduate schools and not getting into
any of them at the beginning I think
sometimes there's a tendency for all of
us but especially students or trainees
coming up to think that our all the
professors just kind of had a straight
path and that things just kind of all
fell in order and then you knew this is
what you're going to do and then you
stepped into this position without
knowing the journey along the way so I
imagine that people hearing about that
aspect of your journey and how you were
able to actually get a better sense of
what you wanted will actually help
people who might be in the middle of
feeling confused or not knowing which
direction to go or getting rejected from
a school and not know if they should
continue so I really appreciate that as
well yeah I just note that sometimes
you know if I think if I had gotten into
grad school that first time I don't
think I would be here
um sometimes you know life just happens
the way it does you know you could say
for a reason or you know it's been
calling or whatever you want to call it
um you know sometimes your best laid
plans are are not the way things go and
maybe that's for the best in the long
run yeah really well said really well
said
Diana how about you your path as we've
heard a little bit about from your bio
but it sounds like it wasn't the path
you predicted definitely definitely not
so I went to high school I grew up in
rural Texas and the town that I went to
high school in like no one really went
to college
and most people didn't finish high
school and so I actually never did
graduate from high school I thought I
knew better I had a job in 12th grade
um I was like you know why go to school
what I can have like a car and a job
that pays minimum wage seems great
and didn't really see the need to move
forward but after the year during which
I should have been finishing High School
I did decide to go to college after all
and because I didn't have a high school
diploma I wasn't really eligible for
most college okay okay so I ended up at
St John's College in Santa Fe New Mexico
because they didn't require a high
school diploma or an s.a.t score and um
I got there not really even knowing what
philosophy was everyone at St John's
gets a degree in philosophy I honestly
thought I'd be reading a lot of Kurt
Vonnegut novels
um and instead I discovered that
phosphere was really quite difficult but
it was a fantastic school it was amazing
you know we read philosophy we read you
know scientific papers we read Newton's
principia we read all the quantum
physics papers they were they were
incredible and at the time I thought oh
maybe I want to be a physicist
um not really knowing what all that
entailed and there was a professor at St
John's who used to take some students up
to Los Alamos National Laboratories
and at Los Angeles at the Laboratories I
met some physicists and they were okay
they weren't that friendly but I met two
Physicians who were working on viral
disorders viral diseases and I thought
they were the the greatest so that's
actually what I decided to go to medical
school instead of anything else and
actually similarly I applied to all the
medical schools in Texas and got into
none but I got into medical school in
New York City at Cornell and um I
remember the day I interviewed I wore a
borrowed dress and some high heels and
it was early January
probably one of the worst days of my
life I'd only lived in Texas Mexico and
New Mexico before then and I had never
faced anything like the gray sludgy
slushy snow and uh it was it was the
interviews each one was worse than the
one before it I thought for sure I
wasn't in and I met with the associate
Dean who was in charge of admissions he
was a incredibly kind thoughtful person
who I do think gave me the chance at
this and um I told him that I was never
going to come to the school and don't
even bother to to accept me and his
response was really you go throw
everything away because of one bad day
sure enough I ended up at medical school
and even in medical school my plan was
to return to Texas and be a primary care
doctor in rural Texas by the end of the
four years I was like no I'm gonna do
Psychiatry instead and then I ended up
in Neuroscience research
and it was definitely you know some
accidents along the way a lot of you
know as as Steven mentioned some you
know some you know powerful mentors
along the way
and um that's how I ended up here wow
that's great here I mean definitely
appreciate that context as well and so
many parallels in your stories too which
I did not anticipate just in terms
definitely in terms of not what you had
planned but even in terms of you know
not getting into schools you'd applied
to the strong role as you mentioned of a
mentor is really kind of shaping and re
redirecting you um and just having again
some of that that resilience too so I
think that speaks that speaks volumes as
a follow-up I'm curious how you think
your path actually impacts you on a
day-to-day basis
um just like the the navigation that you
had to take to get to the current stage
and some of the Serendipity if you want
to call it like how does that actually
impact what you do in your perspective
and Dion we can start with you
you know I definitely view it as you
know I think a lot of life is hard work
but a lot of it is luck and just sort of
lining up and I'm always incredibly
grateful for that and you know the joke
in my family is that you know if there
have been One Missed opportunity I'd
probably be working at the Walmart in
falfurias Texas although my mom says I'd
be the manager so
and it seems appropriate for mom to say
and probably true
you know it's just and so I try to be
mindful of that like and we we all tend
to you things that we've earned feel
very earned but really like so much is
Just a chance and so I'm grateful for
those chances and recognize that that
doesn't happen all the time to other
people and to you know people with small
circumstances for us had incredibly
powerfully positive outcomes but
sometimes it goes away and that's why I
see a lot of my research studies people
who have substance use disorders
don't that's really helpful perspective
Steve what about you
um well I certainly resonate with the
idea of both hard work and luck being
extremely important in this kind of
career
um this is something I always try to
convey to trainees is that there's some
things you can control and some things
you can't and you kind of want to try to
learn what is the difference between
those things and then put yourself in
positions where you can make choices
this is to me the best career advice
that I know how to give I think is is
putting yourself in a place where you
have not just one option that you must
do because that's the only thing on a
table if you can get yourself in a place
where you can choose between A and B
that's almost always going to be better
and um and also being open to things
that you didn't expect to be the choice
you're about to make you know those are
those are that's certainly how my came
about I've seen many other scientists
that that have that um that aspect to
their careers as well they just you know
being open-minded and taking
opportunities when they when they come
or when you put yourself in front of
them
and then I guess in terms of um how my
uh you know history affects my current
perspective on science um I certainly
consider myself a psychologist even
though I do studies in rats and a lot of
it is very you know muscular
Neuroscience genetics and so on
um we I'm very much coming from a
psychological perspective and that's
really how I
um try to approach the the rat brain
trying to understand what our
psychological processes that might exist
in both humans and rats and how can we
you know if we can understand them then
in rats maybe we can get some insights
into humans but also not expecting that
that's always going to be the case
it's really important to recognize
they're not just little furry humans and
even when they for example take drugs uh
voluntarily in my lab which is what
humans are doing in addiction there are
some key differences in most of the
studies that people do
um for example the rats don't have much
else going on in their lives so why
wouldn't they take drugs maybe it's sort
of not a disorder for them in some ways
so these are the kinds of questions I I
really think about a lot in my own lab
and ways to try to improve our rap
models and that certainly comes from my
my training history and the experiences
I've had along the way
yeah really great perspective and
appreciate the words of wisdom that you
all are sharing for people coming up as
well because I think again it's a theme
that comes up repeatedly I mean I
definitely hear that from more senior
scientists or even thinking about some
of the folks at Yale Dr George Henninger
is one that comes to mind who really
facilitate and started a lot of
molecular Psychiatry work there but
hearing his story and how there were so
many things that he didn't anticipate
and basically him just saying like both
of you that he was just ready for the
opportunities that came even though
things that he really wanted to do fell
apart things that he never planned to do
opened up and just being ready to kind
of jump into those opportunities so I
appreciate the way you both mentioned
that context as well
um and again it seems like it's
impacting your work in so many ways even
as you think about how you frame things
as a psychologist who's doing
Neuroscience or as a physician and so I
think that's really really healthy as
well to pick up Steve where you left off
in terms of some of the addiction work
and things like that it's gonna be a
pretty hard pivot but or a quick pivot
but I'd be curious if you both also
could talk a little bit about what you
think the role of science is for society
and Steve you already hinted at that in
terms of some things translate to humans
some things don't like what do you see
is that role and to layer it a little
bit and you can come back to this if you
want also just thinking about all the
mixed feelings that people have in
society in terms of pro science
anti-science
rodents in science and is that helpful
or are we doing things that we shouldn't
be doing so I know that's a whole nother
layer so you don't have to go too much
into that we can come back as well but I
want to at least put it in that broader
context as well
yeah um
so I guess uh there's there's sort of
two things that that are behind my drive
to to ask the kinds of questions that I
try to ask in my own life
um one of them has to do with ultimately
helping people in society by helping to
perhaps treat some of these or come up
with new treatment strategies at least
for uh some of these psychiatric
disorders which are devastating for so
many lives including in my own family
um I will say that this is a huge part
of why I'm studying addiction is when I
was in high school and thinking about
what I'm going to do with my life my
uncle
um he overdosed of a heroin at the time
um and so he was a close uncle and you
know kind of almost took a special shine
to myself and my brother and
um and that just really kind of
um you know just give like a sort of
fire under under me in some ways to to
just try to figure out why would someone
just throw away their life like that you
know for something that just doesn't
make any sense and and seeing also him
at the towards the end um you know my
grandparents who he had lived with uh
they they had um dementia and so they
were kind of declining pretty quickly
and they had a live-in kind of caretaker
and they were you know he was coming by
all the time and just causing all these
problems and he was just being a jerk
you know he was just he was stealing all
the time he was threatening the
caretaker and it was getting to be a
dangerous situation it just was
just so it really opened my eyes to see
someone who you know I loved and I was
close to yeah um just turned into a
different person
um so so obviously this is something
that I think that we need to do better
in in Neuroscience is trying to come up
with a better understanding of how the
brain works normally and how it works in
the context of addiction how did some of
these processes actually work in hopes
that we then can leverage that
information to actually come up with new
treatment strategies and then the other
thing that really drives me um is is
this idea of it actually
um Dr Martinez you mentioned that you
were originally interested in physics
and and that's something that also
another commonality we have um I find
myself especially good at physics I
don't think but um but the idea of kind
of understanding where the what's going
on with the universe like how did the
where do we come from in that way
um it just struck me as one of the
biggest questions and one of the biggest
mysteries out there and um and so I kind
of had in mind that that was something
that I would perhaps like to pursue in
an intellectual way
um but then I Came Upon neuroscience and
I realized that there's like almost as
big of a mystery right here inside of
our heads and so that Jen just really
you know the rest is sort of History I'm
trying to trying to pursue um these
really huge questions that are deeply
meaningful for what it is to be human
and what it is to be you know a person
in society
um that's so that's I guess the two
pillars of kind of um my take on your
question there yeah that's really a
really helpful perspective as well and I
appreciate you know you kind of sharing
where that initial passion and then fire
came from in a lot of ways as well the
only thing anything you want to react to
and what Stephen said or even to answer
the question for yourself as well
sure so if we go to you know how does
how does science fit in with Society I
think it's it's a very compelling
question
um I've I've a number of years ago as
I'm as you mentioned my bio I started
giving talks to high school students and
you know my older son is now 20 when he
was about 15 when he was in high school
there was a party where everyone was
drinking at the party and a girl fell
out of a window in a New York City
apartment building and didn't survive
and when I heard this story I was just
like these are the things that happened
when I was in high school and it's still
you know another generation and we're
still having these issues happen
um from teenage drug use so I started to
take I decided to take the science and
go start talking to parents Educators
and teenagers and you know it was hard
because the first thing I want to do
when you're a parent you have your kids
is you when they're teenagers you want
to be like don't use drugs you'll die
don't use drugs terrible things happen
you know but it doesn't work you know we
know it doesn't work and so I decided to
follow the a model of science-based sex
education with no abstinence pledges
don't work and so what I've been doing
and talking to high school students
generally I start with the parents is
just sort of say you know
experimentation happens
um I don't think parents should
necessarily be
helping that with you know parties or
whatever at their houses but we have to
have talk to kids about safety we have
to talk to them about what accents look
like we have to talk about what an
overdose looks like because actually
teenagers right now are the fastest
growing population of Overdose victims
when it comes to opioids and half of all
assaults involve drugs as well so when I
go into schools I completely stick with
the science you know what my
conversations with drugs with my own
kids and or our own values are different
than the science with my own kids I do
use the science as well but I find it
actually incredibly refreshing like
teenagers will listen I go in I show pet
scans I show data I show data I show
data on like how do you help a friend
how do you do what an overdose looks
like and when do you get help and when
does somebody need naloxone and when do
you call 9-1-1 I talk about what
problematic drug use looks like
especially in the setting of
self-medication talking about like kids
with depression anxiety ADHD are much
more likely to be using drugs because a
little better faster and it's easier to
get your hands on
edible than it is to get psychiatric
care right so yeah and right and so talk
about like what problematic dress drug
use looks like and I think we have to
have these very Frank conversations with
teenagers if we're going to do anything
about
um honestly future addiction because
most drug problems do begin in the
teenage years and it was kind of
terrifying at first to be honest with
you
um not just because I wasn't telling
people you know don't do drugs but
because I was really talking about the
science and I had to learn how to phrase
it in a way that wasn't off-putting yeah
it wasn't annoying and frankly I found
that teenagers like it a lot more when I
talk now I talk to to parents I sort of
I focus on the like you know the Doom
and Gloom the risks you know we're all
gonna die right and when I talk to
teenagers I don't do that at all
um I really just stick with the data and
it's it's refreshing to have it be very
well received
so I have hope for their this younger
generation I have to say
um you know I think it's a time when
before we have these ideas of you before
we have our our fixed ideas and we want
the science to support what we believe
in in some ways you know teenagers just
seem to be much more open to information
and data I guess you know they're still
in school all the time and they know a
lot you know they get on their phones
and they look stuff up
so I don't dare say anything that isn't
backed up by data because I know that on
me out in a minute
I'm curious what do you do ever do a q a
because like you said yeah teens get a
lot of information so at least in my
experience there's often times where
people just want to ask a scientist a
question like I saw this is this legit
is it not or I think it's legit
are you gonna convince me I'm just
curious what like what does that
actually look like when you do q and A's
I've been experi you know I've been
experimenting with a format a fair
amount is easier with with parents you
know it's easier you know but with with
uh with high school students at first I
was talking to schools and I got a very
limited amount of time and it just
doesn't work you have to have the Q a so
now what I've been doing is asking for a
lot more time and the best luck I've had
is actually with the school right around
the corner from here it's on 158 in
Amsterdam where the students set up a
mental health club and I spoke I was
there for two hours answering questions
yeah and it was one of the best times
I've ever had in my job wow wow that's
great questions
yeah I mean it seems like I mean that's
just obviously just a sample of one but
it seems like an ideal way to go to
really just open things up and the fact
that they have that mental health club
already I've been hearing from my only T
my own teenagers about the lack of
conversations around these things
sometimes I mean surprisingly it seems
like and I could be wrong but it seems
like a lot of teenagers actually want
the schools to talk about it more at
least in the conversations I've had and
the schools that I've gone to and talked
but sometimes I'm not sure why this is
but it seems like maybe there's a
perception among our our age group that
they don't want it or we're talking
about too much but that just not has
been has not been my experience talking
to students in the classroom absolutely
they're very interested in psychiatric
disorders we talk about the symptoms we
talk about treatments and I talk a lot
about the interaction between having you
know mental health issues and drug use
and what that looks like yeah
well definitely appreciate the work
you're doing and again I mean I'm just
hearing so many things between but what
you're both saying from different
perspectives and starting points but a
lot of commonalities as well Stephen is
there anything you want to do kind of
jumping on uh yeah I mean um what you
were just saying um really resonates
with me as well in the in the Outreach
I've done to to various age people
um probably not nearly as well as you
but uh but you know you try and um I
will say also from my personal
experience when I was coming up and um
starting to learn for the first time
about drugs it was in the context of uh
the 80s uh kind of War on Drugs um so
just say no and and dare and stuff like
that and um and I actually think in that
case there was some aspects of that
quote education that were ended up being
harmful in some way could end up being
harmful in the sense that there were
some things that were not quite true and
we're a little bit more along the lines
of kind of propaganda basically and you
know I found myself saying you know
reading about for example cannabis and
hearing about how it's going to do all
kinds of terrible things and you should
absolutely stay away from it and then
you know seeing my friends and also
experimenting myself with it at the time
and not dying and not going crazy and so
on and
um and so I guess I then wondered what
else was true and not true about what's
you know so I think that a little bit of
uh I think Honesty is key because as you
said kids are smart they have phones
they can look things up and uh see if
you're lying to them or not and people
don't like being told what to do I don't
think and um but having the information
to make good choices that's the key uh
aspect to this I think exactly the point
that's what I say like I'm providing you
with the information you should have to
make your best choices for yourself and
the other thing that resonates a lot
with teenagers as I talk about watching
out for your friends right talk about
how you know anyone who's
Consciousness is in any way Changed by a
by a drug whether it's cannabis alcohol
and they're not really all completely
awake or completely alert as at risk for
being the victim of an assault and we
have a responsibility to help our
friends they're also at a risk of it
being in an accident not even just car
accidents but riding a bike walking in
the freezing cold I talk about how like
almost everyone has gone to a party and
had too much and people get embarrassed
and scared and they try and solve the
problem on their own and that's probably
where there's the biggest risk of danger
and why we should why we should help
each other and that actually resonates
with teenagers very well is keeping an
eye out for you know their friends and
their their fellow peers yeah it's
really good I'm even imagining people
who are listening who are just going to
take some of the advice not that you're
giving advice in that sense but some of
the things that you've learned and
actually apply that as well and I do
appreciate how you put that in context
because you said at the beginning that
you're experimenting you weren't exactly
sure how it would go you were nervous so
it seems like you gave yourself space to
learn that as well which I think is key
and actually just ties into you know
what we heard about from Steve and Steve
in your bio as well just having that
learning process and really taking the
time to see what's effective and what
resonates with people so I think that's
huge
yeah it took a while with the teenagers
but I I kind of finally got I practiced
on my own kids for a while they're like
Mom we're sick of hearing it I'm like
yeah that's the best that's the most
critical and most helpful audience
though if they're willing to go there
with you because they'll tell you
straight up whether it's uh resonate or
not I can I mean I can tell also that
you have a lot of um authenticity about
it as well just being realistic about
the situation I know that definitely
will resonate with the groups that
you're speaking to
and and we have a lot more data than you
know you experimenting with drug use in
the 80s I understand that completely but
you know it's now 2020s and we have you
know 40 Years of data so we're really
now going with data yeah and and we you
know we have all of this we have all
this incredible just treasure chest of
information and
um and an audience wants to hear it
definitely agree
well in a lot of ways you know you all
are
preaching I'm preaching to the choir in
a sense because this is this is what you
are all both passionate about until
you've taken initiative and having good
science communication but if you remove
yourself from the equation for a moment
and just think about Society at large
let's go let's go a little bit smaller
let's just think about the scientific
and medical Enterprise that's probably
not the right word to use but I'll use
it anyway how well do you think we
actually communicate about science to
the general public and those around us
not you all as individuals but just more
globally Steve you look like you're
ready to jump in yeah I think we need to
do way better
um is the long story short
um you know part of the issue here is
that uh it's one of the realities that
people may or may not be familiar with
with regard to science in at least in
the United States is that um
you know so for example we study
addiction and we are funded largely by
the National Institutes of Health which
and specifically by the National
Institute on drug abuse
um which is uh
ultimately means that the research we're
doing should have a specific application
to Health in humans
um to help treat people with addiction
for example or to identify risk factors
for addiction and so on and I think a
lot of our research does try to do that
but I think there's also a lot of
research that is funded by the National
Institutes of Health that may sort of be
described as being coming you know
perhaps we'll come up with the next cure
or the next breakthrough
um but in fact it's really basic science
and I think that's okay like I think
that ultimately what the brain is such a
mystery and and the how psychiatric
disorders work and why one person has
one and one doesn't with seemingly
similar genetic predispositions and
environmental experiences and things
it's it's very mysterious and and I
think it is it's just the fact that we
need to understand how the brain works
better in the first place and not
everything we're going to do is going to
have health impacts in the short term
and I think there's some some tension
there because ultimately the National
Institutes of Health is funded by the
federal government and for health
purposes and so um and it's sort of an
uncomfortable fact that when we tell
politicians that we're doing basic
science that's probably not going to
have short-term benefits to to Americans
that is maybe maybe we get cut the
budgets get cut faster and things like
that and so there's this little like
sort of um I don't quite want to call it
a fiction but I think a little bit of a
um a failure on our part to be open
about this reality and I think the
downside of it is is something that
probably most of us have experienced
when you see on the news that the new
breakthrough for whatever is out there
and you know it's going to change
everything and then it doesn't or you
know this whatever it is eggs are good
for you eggs are bad for you all that
kind of stuff it just makes it seem like
science is just you know up up for grabs
like anyone could have their own opinion
if just as good as a scientific finding
and that's not the case and I think we
need to be better about communicating
the fact that science isn't perfect it
is in process being wrong making a guess
that is wrong and has proven wrong is
called progress and that's not failure
it's actually it's actually how we make
progress
um these are the kinds of things I think
we scientists need to be a little bit
more um a little bit better at conveying
to the general public yeah really well
said a follow-up question because you're
given some concrete examples you have
thoughts either of you on how we
actually do that the scientists like
what might be some effective practice
and I realize I'm getting into kind of
Behavioral Science and you know
organizational psychology not even
organizational but just Community
psychology and those types of things but
curious if you all had any thoughts on
that Eddie hour
I'm serious though in that this is the
kind of you know cross-cutting
conversations that I think really can
resonate with different audiences maybe
someone plans your podcast through
um through a faith-based um uh Avenue
maybe some are neuroscientists some are
coming from you know there's a lot of
different places that you end up
watching this podcast or listening to
this podcast and that then exposes
people that are not necessarily or sort
of think Neuroscience is too complicated
or something with you know the kind of
conversations that you're having here I
think it can potentially make a
difference in the world I definitely
appreciate that and to share a story I
mean I have seen that as well because as
you know as I've done kind of the
standard academic thing of talking at
different schools I've had faculty
members who've told me oh I have you
know I have a sister who's not a
scientist who told me about your podcast
so it does seem like in those ways it is
at least penetrated into different
audiences and people are picking it up
and having conversations that they might
not have otherwise so
that's definitely encouraging and even
though I laughed at it I didn't expect
you to say that but still definitely
encouraging
Dan what about you for answering just a
question of how and then maybe going
back after that to the question of if we
do a good job at all
I actually think they fit together
because you know I like the example of
eggs are good eggs are bad you've that's
part of the the problem is that you know
when it comes to
when it comes to just sort of like
boiling science down into a little bitty
sound wise it doesn't work right because
it's complicated right eggs are so good
for some people bad for other people I
always you I do also give some um I do
some CME courses on medicinal cannabis
to other Physicians and you know does
cannabis cure everything no is it
completely harmless no and so it's
complicated so you can't for example
cannabis is is good for or it can help
with pain anxiety and insomnia that's
great if you're treating a patient with
multiple sclerosis or with cancer pain
but not if you're treating an 18 year
old with ADHD so you know it's you know
the problem is is we know a lot more but
it's complicated and it's very hard to
just sort of parse it down into one
little tiny uh you know three line
article or one little tiny you know bit
on a on a news channel it really does
require forums in which you can have
longer conversations and sort of explain
the nuances so you need to have more
sort of patience on the part of
society at large with science because
it's not so simple anymore
yes we've all said I mean that thing
that you're mentioning too is just being
able to slow down I guess the conundrum
is how do you slow down in the society
that is only speeding up yeah and I mean
you know in some ways
I would say uh you know I'm guilty of
kind of trying to at least use that to
an advantage as well I mean you all
might know we actually have some like we
launched a tick tock Channel too which
is more sound bite but trying to at
least craft a way to at least pull in
enough to give something that sounds but
not maybe full because you can't always
get into nuances and knowing how to do
that I mean I think in some ways too
what I've heard from others is just um
and Diana this gets to your work too but
the utility of actually starting in
schools too where you can actually
incorporate this into kids language
early on so one example I had an
opportunity to speak to um all the
superintendents and Boards of Education
in the state of Connecticut a few months
back and to hear some of the teachers
who were there also talk about the ways
they're incorporating some of the
language in elementary school and having
the kids think about the prefrontal
cortex and regulating emotions so like
at that point there's more time to kind
of really nurture that understanding not
to say that we should give up on adults
but it's a very different type of
conversation in terms of
speed the conversation attention spam
willingness to listen and all the other
things as adults we've learned to um
what's the best way to put it condition
is is it one aspect of it but just
having I'm using all these words
incorrectly it's not hardwired but I
feel like we act as if it's hardwired we
have so many thoughts that we're like
this is the way the world is I mean we
do that as scientists we do that in
society and to really have time to kind
of break that up and start all over
again I think is important but in some
ways easier to do with younger folks who
are more open to actually hearing those
things especially when you come with
that authenticity that Diana mentioned
so I feel like that was a little bit of
a tangent but
the other thing I think that um that we
can do is as as neuroscientist or
scientists
is to um is to kind of try to open up
the field to more kinds of people to
diverse perspectives reverse populations
of people so that we can you know you
know I mean I guess like the way science
is often perceived is like you know you
have some Egghead in a lab coat or
something and they're just you know not
something that I do that's not a person
like me and I think when you start to to
it you know have people interact with
with these with kids of coming from
different backgrounds and things and who
then can bring in their own perspectives
and and ideas new ideas
um this is this is another path forward
I think is to is to really try to
um you know try something a little
different you know I would argue that
our Neuroscience that we've had so far
has not been very successful at helping
people or not as much as it could and I
think this might be part of the problem
is we are a little bit too heavily
focused on the exact thing that you know
we've always studied um and I think we
um we need new ideas
yeah really well said and yeah I don't
know if I'm putting you on the spot here
but as Steve mentioned that makes me
think of the philosophy talk that you
gave at an addiction conference to
neuroscientist and how
much of a shift that was and that's I
mean that's why Steve and I has such a
long conversation afterwards because
forcing us to think about things in a
different way that we don't always think
about although I feel like some of it
was there but when most of us just don't
articulate or take the time to actually
delve into that so I'm curious if you
you know on the spot we want to share at
least some of the things that you've
been thinking about around those Realms
so just as one example of integrating
from different perspectives
yeah so what I was asked to give that
talk because I have my undergraduate
degree was in philosophy and when I was
asking the talk my first reaction was
like yeah sure why not and then I
thought about it I'm like what am I
going to say
honestly like I spent probably I spent
many months working on that talk I was
it was really like really given thought
long and hard about it like I I don't
know what I'm gonna say and it actually
had a real change in my career thinking
about that talk because what I really
try to think about in that talk was what
do we mean when we think of bad what do
we mean when we think of bad behavior
and we think of you know injury to sell
for injury to others and so I try to
take examples of psychiatric disorders
that involve harm to others and the top
of that list is you anti-social
personality disorder and pedophilia and
I ask myself you know are these are
these brain disorders and
um did a lot of research on them have
started a new project looking at
anti-social personalities or view it as
being
anti-social in a personality disorder
but really if you break it down into its
pieces it comes down to impulsive
impulse control impulsivity and I think
there's a lot of data to suggest that it
that there's
um difficulty understanding social
situations and most people have
anti-social personality disorder they
don't understand the situation well and
when it doesn't go in the way that they
expect it to the reaction is anger and
we all have situations in which we have
a social interaction that doesn't go the
way we expect it to and sometimes we
react with sadness or shame or
embarrassment
or anger and when we react with anger
it's because we think we're right
so when you and I have a social
interaction that doesn't go well and we
we react with something other than anger
we think that oh maybe maybe we're wrong
right somebody who reacts with anger
tends to not understand what happened
and so I've been trying to do more
research and anti-social personality
disorder looking at impulsivity and
social cognition
trying to start that up and then I also
in that talk I talked about pedophilia
which was that was tough you know like I
asked myself the question is pedophilia
or brain disorder and I think I
mentioned like my first reaction was
like Lord I don't know and I don't want
to know
the second reaction was I really don't
want the FBI banging down my door
um but you know I've I've been looking
up and reading more about it it's deeply
understudied and honestly you know we we
shy away from it but it is a brain
disorder and honestly what would be the
worst that happens if we were to find a
treatment there may be fewer future
victims and you still can't get our head
around it it's completely understudied
it's underfunded there hasn't been a
grant funded since 2008. what's
interesting to me about pedophilia and
this is a study what I do down the road
although hopefully no one's listening
for my institution because I think I
have a freak out if I do this study but
there is some hiss to suggest that
there's a lot of overlap between
obsessive thinking and pedophile and I
wonder if we could look at it more from
the perspective of OCD
um especially at least in in patients
who want treatment which is the place to
start
even though I mostly do neuroscience and
addiction and certainly you know
anti-social personality disorder has a
lot of overlap with addiction and I
think pedophilia does too I think
there's a lot of substance use we don't
really know I'm starting to move and
look and see if we can get Beyond just
thinking of these as being fixed Bad
Brains into thinking like can we break
it down into the symptoms because we
know how to treat some of these symptoms
yeah that's really really well said and
I appreciate I mean there's so many
pieces that you brought up to just in
terms of you know flying out for what
what Stephen was mentioning about the
ways that we communicate but then even a
layer beneath that what do we actually
think about and investigate and study
and what do we shy away from and all the
reasons see if you look like you might
have a comment to jump in with yeah um I
mean it's just fascinating and obviously
like you know pedophilia I think is not
something we do talk about very much as
a scientific field and I think the
reason is because the first thing that
comes to mind is you know disgust or you
know these maybe people are evil or
there's something like really you know
bad about them and so on and that's the
case in a very real way
um and I would say that that is to some
extent also the case with addiction many
times we even though we know that there
is ultimately in some way addiction is a
brain disorder as well it does cause
people to do terrible things to other
people and to themselves certainly and I
think that's also a little bit an aspect
of a lot of us I think disorders
something wrong with you that's like a
bad thing there's something bad about
you and I don't think we really have
that impression of other types of brain
disorders like Alzheimer's disease for
example or Parkinson's disease I don't
think anyone really is frequently
blaming those people and thinking
they're they're bad because their brain
is broken and it's causing them to have
um you know lots of problems and I'd
argue that's because we understand those
disorders a little bit better we have
something that's biological that it like
actually causes it whereas in for
example addiction people are just making
bad choices and that is the disorder in
some ways and that's you know hard to
get your head around how this thing
could be you know how a person can you
know kind of have free will and yet
still be controlled by their you know
brain in some way and I don't know it's
just these are really tough topics to
wrestle with and obviously especially
for for something as sensitive as
pedophilia yeah yeah
I mean definitely like even as I'm
listening to both of you talk this kind
of ties everything back together because
it speaks to both how much more we need
to be talking about and thinking about
and investigating these things
so if we're not even doing that how can
we actually communicate it to the public
if we can't even have those
conversations ourselves so you know do
you want to hear what you're already
wrestling through and trying to think
about that type of work I think is so
important and it gets back to I mean the
work that we have to do internally in a
sense and also externally not that any
of us can do it on our own but something
that we kind of have to do in
collaboration uh with one another so I
mean I think this is it's helpful
because it's a good it's a challenge
point it speaks to the hope that can
come from that but also the reality of
the fact that there's still work to be
done in a lot of ways
thank you
and certainly you know when it comes to
anti-social personality disorder which I
mean most of my participants are in my
studies will most all have substance use
disorders and a fair number really do
have either anti-social personality
disorder or on in that sort of range of
things and I don't want people who
completely lack we often think of
anti-social personality disorders
completely lacking empathy that's not
actually really the case it was a really
nice study done recently that
interviewed 3 000 people with
anti-social personality disorder and
only 20 reported symptoms like lack of
empathy hurting cruelty to animals and
bullying most of the symptoms are things
like you're not paying rent not
following through quitting a job without
a job to follow up with
um you know the stealing you know
certainly behaviors that are are
problematic but aren't necessarily sort
of like you know a monster-like lack of
empathy or sympathy and so I do think we
have an obligation for this patient
population because studies show that 40
of patients with opioid use disorder
have aspd and if we treat this part of
it then 40 of people may not respond to
our treatments yeah to bring it back to
rodents I think one thing that we do
need to be looking at and something that
I think is happening in the rodent field
you all have to tell me more is sort of
you're looking at the role of social
stress and social status and social and
how that fits and when it comes to
substance use disorders comorbidity is a
huge issue anxiety depression aspd ADHD
but all those comorbidities have in
common
um impaired Social function
so I think that's one thing that runs
across psychiatrics it could be they
could be modeled in animal studies and
really and really help us
yeah and we frequently I will say as the
as an animal researcher we frequently
don't do that and I and I think that's
really I couldn't agree with you more
that this was a huge aspect of
human life of all these disorders you're
talking about and also of rat's lives
and I don't know if they have disorders
or not but they certainly suffer from
social isolation for example they care
what other rats think of them that kind
of thing and um you know how could it be
the case that that's irrelevant for the
kind of Neuroscience studies we're doing
it seems impossible but I I argue that
the real reason the main reason why we
don't uh study these we I mean I think
there's a lot of Neuroscience would
agree with that statement but we still
don't study it so why maybe one of the
reasons is simply that it's it's hard
it's more it's more inconvenient to add
those variables into your studies
there's not a lot of interest from
funding sources to do these again basic
science kinds of questions to try to
understand these more difficult um but
probably extremely important factors
um so yeah I think there's a there's a
growing as you said a growing group of
people that are starting to realize that
we are simply missing a huge part of the
puzzle here if we're studying rats in
solitary confinement and seeing how much
they take drugs which they don't know
are illegal they're not illegal for them
they're not they don't know anything
about the health consequences why
wouldn't a rat take drugs in my lab you
know there's ways we can get at that we
can say you know you must choose between
hanging out with a buddy and taking some
drug for example now we're in the
ballpark of the kind of choices people
are really making when they're addicted
yeah
yeah really well said
well this has been a great conversation
uh in True Form I think we've covered a
lot of ground in terms of the work that
you're both doing in research
um and but then also in community and
society and I think you also have nicely
given a lot of challenges uh to folks as
well so I will say by by way of story it
has been nice and this goes back to
Steve's comment about the ADI hour but
it's been nice to see the ways that
people have actually been using the
podcast whether that be like a loose
Journal Club type of thing where you
know institutes are watching it and
having a conversation in small groups
afterwards or universities have reached
out and actually want to use episodes
for courses and things like that so I
mentioned that because I think a lot of
what you both have talked about would be
really helpful for people to actually
incorporate into a classroom setting or
into a journal Club setting or research
discussion to really think about where
are the points that we really need to
kind of push things forward both within
our research Endeavors but in society in
a larger way as well so obviously you
you both are here so you can disseminate
the uh the podcast of those in your
spheres of influence but I mean there's
ways I think that we could actually even
do that more because just because of all
the important topics that you both have
brought up which I think are really
relevant and important for us
um on a much broader scale so definitely
appreciate the ways that you both have
done that any closing words that you
want to leave with audience members I'm
going to leave it wide open because
there's lots of stuff that we've talked
about and directions you could take
things but
yeah um so you mentioned that you were
doing some some Tick Tock videos and
honestly I think Tick Tock is a great
way to go like I think Tick Tock can
handle you know what I was talking about
like sort of like complex
um you know that science is complicated
in Little Bits at a time like you know
some Tick Tock videos have
misinformation but there are also some
that just sort of like in a short period
of time can explain like you know the
importance of I don't know like you how
allergies work or dental yeah mental
health and so you know it it can you can
break you can break complicated
scientific conversations down into into
bits that can fit into short formats I
think I mean it's a challenge but I
think it's it's doable yeah
well I'm glad you feel that way and that
helps as we're continuing to uh to
Endeavor to do that so that's great
advice
yeah I guess um
you know that not not everyone can be
great at everything so a lot of
scientists are fantastic at their
research are fantastic at you know lots
of aspects of their life
writing papers grants Etc but maybe
they're really bad science communicators
and that's okay you know not everyone
has to do everything and that's why I
think we need to value a bunch of
different kinds of skills not just the
ones that are how much money can you get
on grants and how many papers and what
impact the high profile journals and
things like that that's fine and it's
important but but you know we need to
have uh also people that can actually do
a tick tock channel that kids will want
to hear that can actually communicate
and it across disciplines across kind of
perspectives like you are here with this
podcast uh you know this is this is
something that I'm really it's very
happy that you are performing this
service and I'm you know as I said
before honored to be you know play a
tiny role of the 41st episode of it here
uh we need to do more of this and thank
you for uh Leading The Way of course
well as as you know because you saw my
uh newsletter this week I feel like this
is a huge collaboration just with folks
like you so many people who've come on
the podcast to really share because I
think that's also something that
resonates with people to be able to hear
something about one topic from a whole
bunch of different perspectives and it
goes back to both of the things that you
all have mentioned so it's been an honor
for me as well this has been a really
really fun conversation and you know I'm
saying that with sincerity that I hope
people really amplify what you all have
talked about today because there really
is a potential for this to really kind
of transform how people are thinking
about things on a day-to-day basis and
big picture as well so thanks to both of
you for your uh your support your
willingness to jump on and for
everything that you shared with the
listeners today
great thank you it's great to be here of
course
[Music]